اب مجھے پاکستان کے موضوع کی طرف بڑھنا ہے۔
ہم نے ابھی حال ہی میں عمران خان کو بطور وزیر اعظم منتخب ہوتے دیکھا ہے۔ اور اس پر بہت سارے مختلف طرح کے ردعمل سامنے آتے دیکھے ہیں۔
کچھ لوگوں کو امید ہے کہ وہ ملک کو تبدیل کرنے میں کامیاب ہوگا۔ آپ کو پتا ہوگا
ملٹری کی جنتا، جہاں آپ رون کارلی پر کھڑے ہوتے ہیں۔.
میں تب سے عمران کا ایک پرجوش حامی ہوں جب وہ پاکستانی کرکٹ ٹیم کی کپتانی کر رہا تھا
اور
اور سچ پوچھیں تو اس نے مجھ سے مشورہ کیا۔
جلد ہی وہ ریٹائر ہو رہا تھا اور
ہم نے اکٹھے لنچ کیا اور اس نے کہا آپ کیا مشورہ دیتے ہیں
کیونکہ آپ ان لوگوں میں جو عمر یا اس جیسی کسی چیز کی پروا نہیں کرتے اور جدوجہد میں لگے رہتے ہیں۔
میں نے کہا کہ آپ اپنی جدوجہد جاری رکھیں لیکن صرف اپنے کھلاڑیوں کے لئے۔
عمران نے کہا کہ آپ ایمانداری سے مشورہ دیں کہ آپ کے خیال میں مجھے کیا کرنا چاہئے؟
میں نے جواب میں کہا کہ میرا مشورہ ہے کہ آپ پاکستان میں ایک ایسا فلمی انسٹی ٹیوٹ قائم کرنے کے لئے اپنے اثر و رسوخ اور پیسے کا استعمال کریں
جہاں ہم نوجوان فلم سازوں اور اداکاروں کو تیار کریں اور آپ خود اس کے سربراہ بن سکتے ہیں اور ایکٹر بھی۔
جیسے ہندوستان میں امیتابھ بچن جیسے اداکار نے کیا
میں نے کہا کہ بہت کم اداکار واقعتا اداکاری کرتے ہیں ورنہ ہدایتکار ہی انہیں بتاتا ہے کہ انہیں کیا کرنا ہے۔
تو اس نے کہا کہ تم میری ٹانگ کھینچ رہے ہو۔
میں نے کہا میں نے تم سے مہ مشورے کا وعدہ کیا تھا لہذاد میں ہرگز ایسا نہیں کر رہا۔
گند ہے
پاکستانی سیاست میں اور پاکستان میں مجھے نہیں لگتا کہ آپ بہت دور آجائیں گے۔ لیکن اس نے مجھےغلط ثابت کر دیا۔
وہ ملک کا وزیر اعظم بن گیا ہے۔ تو اگرچہ وہ بہت آگے چلا گیا ہے۔ لیکن وہ جو کچھ کر سکتا ہے
لیکن اس کا کردار محدود رہے گا۔ فوج کے باعث اور پاکستان کے، اور شاید دنیا کے بدترین بدعنوان سیاسی طبقوں میں سے ایک کے باعث۔
یہ طبقے اتنے کرپٹ ہیں کہ وہ نجی محفلوں میں اس کا اعتراف کرتے ہوئے بھی نہیں شرماتے ۔
یہ نائرجیریا کہں سے بن گیا۔
دنیا کا سب سے بدعنوان ملک
یو این کی مدد سے تیار شدہ فہرست میں
حالانکہ ہم نے انہیں کرپشن کرنے میں ہر بار شکست دی ہے۔ شاید ہمیں رابطہ کرنا چاہیے
ان لوگوں سے جو یہ لسٹ بناتے ہیں تاکہ یہ بات یقینی بنائی جا سکے کہ سرفہرست صرف ہم رہیں۔ یہ مایوسی کی انتہا ہے۔
تو بیچارہ عمران کیا کرسکے گا؟ میرا مطلب ہے، آپ کو تو پتا ہے کہ وہ نہیں کرسکتا۔ اس طرح کی سیاست اس کی فطرت ہی میں نہیں۔
اگر وہ صرف مزید اسپتال بناتا ہے تو یہ ایک ایم قدم ہوگا۔ ہم یہ فرض کرلیتے ہیں
لیکن دوسری  طرف آپ جانتے ہیں کہ اس کی پارٹی کے لوگ اس سے پہلے والی حکومتوں کا حصہ تھے۔ مثلاً اس کا موجودہ وزیر خارجہ
اس سے پہلے دوسری سویلین اور فوجی حکومتوں میں بھی وزیر خارجہ رہ چکا ہے۔
یہ وہی چھوٹا سا گروپ ہے جو بار بار آگے آرہا ہے۔
لہذا عمران اس وجہ سے بہت سے نوجوانوں کی حمایت حاصل نہیں کر سکا۔
اس کی نوجوان قیادت میں سے کوئی بھی وہ کام نہیں کر رہا ہے
ان کی حوصلہ افزائی کرنی چاہیے کہ وہ ایسے کام کریں جو انہیں کرنا چاہیے۔ مجھے ڈر ہے، شاید میں غلط ثابت ہوں،
لیکن مجھے لگتا ہے کہ یہ سب کچھ بری طرح سے ختم ہوگا۔